[Applaudissements]
entendez-vous le temps qui passe
pour certains c'est peut-être même le
supplice de la goutte
j'aimerais vous amener quelque part où
le temps s'écoule inlassablement sans
être affectées par aucune de nos
perceptions une goutte à la fois
partons dans les profondeurs de la terre
dans les grottes et même dans les
grottes immergées qui se sont remplis
d'eau quand je suis en exploration dans
les entrailles de la terre
parfois je me demande mais qu'est ce que
je fais la rouille pas juste dans les
grottes sur la planète de façon générale
qui ne s'est pas déjà posé cette
question
peut-être même que en ce moment vous
vous la poser c'est vrai quand même
parce que on est sur une planète peuplée
de différence d'antagonisme 7 milliards
de personnes et toutes ces différences
qui sont soulignés au crayon gras dans
l'immédiat tous les jours qu'est-ce
qu'on a tous en commun qu'est ce qu'on
fait là depuis que je suis enfant je me
pose toutes ces questions et je ne sais
pas si c'est à cause de mes lectures
mais j'ai envie de découvrir quelque
chose c'est fou quand on est enfant jeu
mais j'ai envie de découvrir comme un
trésor quelque chose et puis peut-être
que secrètement j'ai envie d'être un
super héros ça ne vous est pas déjà
arrivé et puis vous devinez bien ce qui
s'est passé il y a un jour quelqu'un qui
m'a dit ben voyons dans le hockey à
l'époque j'étais en france leur sap a
été ben voyons donc mais c'était ma
pauvre enfant c'est impossible
c'est fou y a quand même toujours
quelqu'un quelque part ou pire nous
mêmes pour nous casser nos rêves et
notre quête
alors évidemment tous mes rêves ont pris
la poussière et j'en suis arrivé à me
dire que tout ça n'existait pas que
c'était une hallucination et j'en suis
arrivé à les oublier complètement
jusqu'au jour où par hasard ou presque
enfin si le hasard existe je me suis
retrouvé sous terre et la boum comme un
coup de foudre
vous savez quand vous sortez votre coeur
battre en un instant une seule balle
dans les entrailles de la terre
ravivant moi toutes ces questions je ne
pouvais pas faire la sourde oreille
une deuxième fois surtout maintenant je
suis adulte
alors voilà je pars à la découverte de
ce qui se passe sous la surface de la
terre et sous la surface de l'eau pas
juste dans les océans sous la surface de
l'eau qui enfermé dans la terre imaginez
un instant vous flotter librement sans
aucune résistance dans des galeries que
personne n'a vu avant vous pas besoin
d'aller sur mars
des galeries comme celle là il y en a
partout et sur tous les continents
alors chaque plongée je découvre des
formations de stalactites et de
stalagmites que je n'aurais pas pu
imaginer
formé de dépôt de calcite de minéraux de
formes et de couleurs immunité et tous à
former une goutte d'eau à la fois je
partage ma passion avec des explorateurs
de partout dans le monde et je pense à
un livre que j'ai lu mon enfant de jules
verne voyage
centre de la terre et je me dis mais est
ce que dans ce roman c'est de la pure
fiction aussi finalement quelque part il
n'y aurait pas des galeries des lames
gérante qui nouvelle irait tous les uns
avec les autres
je sais pas peut-être fiction réalité
édité virtuel et lorsque je me promène
dans ses galeries tout un coup je me
sens connectée avec la planète avec mère
nature et je me rends compte que je suis
dans un endroit vraiment unique 70% de
la terre est composé de 3 % d'eau douce
sous forme de glaciers ou autre et
seulement 1% et de l'eau liquide
potentiellement potable et là à ce
moment dans ce réseau aquifère je suis
dans un tiers de ce pourcentage
je me rends compte que je suis dans un
endroit ce tellement unique et si
fragile et j'en oublie la roche pourtant
magnifiquement sculpté et je ne vois que
cette eau qui me porte
cette eau sans qui je ne peux survivre
plus de trois jours peut-être cinq un
jour parmi toutes mes explorations
je me retrouve en chine dans une région
tellement isolés qui n'ont jamais vu
d'occidentaux en chair et en os
imaginez-vous leur stupeur lorsque je
leur annonce que je viens de parcourir
trente six heures d'avion et de voitures
tout ça pour aller me balader dans les
réseaux d'eau souterraine en dessous de
leurs villages ils se disent qu'ils
doivent nous craindre que nous sommes
venus voler un trésor dans ses galeries
pire nous allons fâché le dieu des
sources l on se tarir entre eux et moi
il y à un abysse entre nos réalités
notre quotidien un gouffre surtout
lorsqu'ils me voient habillé comme un
astronaute ou un extraterrestre comme
vous voulez tout absolument tout nous
sépare mais mais grâce à notre
interprète et à force de montrer les
vidéos et les photos que nous avons
prises sous l'eau
tranquillement nous arrivons à faire
tomber les barrières de la méfiance et
de notre ignorance et à ce moment là la
magie opère chaque expédition est
l'occasion de se revoir on en est arrivé
à se comprendre et tranquillement on en
est arrivé à s'apprécier à s'aimer et ce
qui nous relie
ce sont ces rivières souterraines ces
rivières de vie parce que cette eau
dense et rivières elle est précieuse
seulement 6 % de l'eau du réseau
aquifère va se renouveler au cours de
votre vie je plonge dans l'or bleu le
trésor le plus fragile et le plus
précieux sur notre planète et à ce
moment là ce ne sont plus juste les
rivières souterraines qui me pose
question
mais toutes les sources d'eau douce sur
la planète au fin fond du monde comme au
pied de chez moi
enfin je rêvais de découvrir un trésor
caché bien évidemment mais je me rends
compte qu'il est juste là devant moi à
mes pieds et tout trésor ce qu'il
demande c'est d'être protégés
et pourtant cette eau si fragile sans
qui on ne peut pas vivre plus de trois
jours peut-être 5
elle est surexploité sur polluer
pollution industrielle agricole est tout
simplement humaine mais comment on en
est arrivé là
et surtout qu'est ce qu'on fait
maintenant avec tout ça oh bien sûr il
ya toujours savez ce quelqu'un qui va
vous dire ouais bah de toute façon on ne
peut rien faire c'est trop tard la
planète elle trop pollué ou pire
ouais ben c'est pas si grave que ça
c'est cyclique puis tu fasses on ne peut
rien faire
ah oui vraiment on peut rien faire en
écoutant le corps d'enfant que rien
n'arrête
ou presque j'en suis finalement devenu
être exploratrice et peut-être que je
vais devenir un peu malgré moi une sorte
de super héros mais vous inquiétez pas
pas un super héros solitaire l'ex à cap
no no no no no un super héros du
quotidien pour sauvegarder la qualité de
notre eau potable mais un super héros
parmi plein de super héros d'ailleurs je
suis sûr que parmi vous il y en a il y
en a déjà beaucoup parmi les sept
milliards de personnes sur cette planète
jules verne lui dans son roman il
voulait rejoindre le centre de la terre
finalement il a fait une jonction entre
deux pays
moi je voulais trouver des galeries dans
ces labyrinthes trouver des belles
formations rocheuses
mais ce que j'ai découvert c'est qu'à
travers les sens de l'eau potable
sommeille en nous une humanité
universelle qui nous lie tous les uns
aux autres bon mais avec tout ça qu'est
ce qu'on fait comment fait-on pour
sauvegarder ce trésor et puis pas juste
l'eau mais notre milieu de vie notre
environnement
je sais pas en revenant à l'essence de
la vie aux sources à la base lorsque
j'ai commencé mon projet d'odyssée
urbaine aquatique
j'ai voulu me pencher sur le fleuve
saint-laurent et voir ce qu'on pouvait
faire pour lui vu qu'ils nous en donnent
tant parce que 80% de notre eau potable
vient de ce fleuve
alors je me suis dit que tous ensemble
un pas à la fois une goutte d'eau à la
fois on y arriverait tout simplement en
réduisant notre utilisation de plastique
en ramassant les déchets laissés dans le
passé en réduisant notre consommation de
pesticides herbicides médicaments et
autres produits chimiques dont on n'a
pas forcément besoin
la terre elle elle va continuer
d'évoluer une bulle d'eau à la fois mais
nous qu'est ce qu'on va faire
alors aujourd'hui j'ai une question
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à devenir un
super héros du quotidien avec moi pour
que jamais l'une ayant à nous dire qu'il
ne nous reste plus que trois jours à
survivre merci la manche